[Music]
delivery is picking up steam in the
United States analysts project a steady
increase in the share of delivery sales
at restaurants over the next several
years but what's convenient for
customers might not be best for the
restaurants part of the challenge is the
cost of working with third-party apps
which analysts say will be servicing
many of these orders but this trend is
hitting a nerve in the restaurant
business these bar charts can help
explain why this analysis compares meal
prices for cost for in-store service and
delivery by a third-party app when
restaurants serve food in their store
their margins are up to 69 percent of
the total check and the same meal
ordered via an app well that's the price
of convenience for you additional costs
in labor packing and fees to the apps
make the profit margin sink to thirty
nine percent of the total check on
average food sellers will pay
third-party services a fee of ten to 25
percent on each order vendors who
partner with third-party apps also lose
control over valuable customer data for
restaurants who want to bypass
third-party apps and still get into the
delivery game there are other costs
consider Panera's delivery business the
chain spent six years building it it
costs upwards of a hundred million
dollars to develop its online ordering
system that investment cut into profits
for three years but the effort began to
pay off in 2016 today each delivery
costs about five dollars after
accounting for labor gas and packaging
but to avoid turning away customers
Panera charges a flat delivery fee of
three dollars per order in most markets
this means that they have to sell a lot
more per order to absorb those costs
many smaller restaurants can't afford
that kind of investment order-taking
systems must be developed drivers have
to be hired a third-party app might take
care of those logistics but they take a
commission and typically customers
aren't keen to pay the difference
according to a survey by till stirred
85% of consumers aren't willing to pay
more than $5 for restaurant delivery and
customers may wind up unhappy anyway
because many restaurants sell food that
doesn't travel well this analysis from
Cohen & Co reveals a rise in the share
of orders from steak houses and burger
chains delivery staples like pizza or
Indian foods are losing pace but the
businesses that previously dominated the
delivery market sold food that can stay
tasty for longer periods of time whereas
say french fries prepped in store
probably won't make it to your doorstep
tasting their best and when that order
of fries shows up cold consumers tend to
blame the food seller even if it was
delivered by a third-party app despite
the shortcomings the rise of delivery
seems inevitable though the field is
crowded third-party delivery platforms
are expected to rise in value over the
next few years which means that like it
or not many urban restaurants may soon
have to embrace a brave new world of
food delivery